the following is a conversation with
siraj raval siraj has one of the largest
channels in the machine learning youtube
space over 700 000 people are subscribed
to him as of this state uh
siraj pumped out lots and lots of videos
on topics such as coding tutorials
explaining beginner's concept in machine
learning and in other topics like
blockchain or other computer science
things now his rise came to an abrupt
stop when a series of scandals hit him
at the end of 2019
and there were a lot of articles written
back then twitter posts made and even
siraj himself made an apology video
but i was wondering how did he feel like
during all of this what did he think
back then how did he come to this
how did he feel during the highs and the
lows of his career and how does he look
back on things now
i was struck by how straightforward
siraj was in this conversation i was
sure there was going to be wisdom in
there for the rest of us be that
youtubers or machine learners and i was
not disappointed
he was definitely honest looking back
with a different view
and we touched on many things in this
conversation i hope you enjoy it i hope
you find something in there that helps
you and yeah let us know what you think
well hello everyone um today is is a
special day um
in in many ways uh
siraj who is my guest today is one of
the the pioneers of the field of ml
youtube now i'm pretty sure
uh pretty much every single person in
the field has heard of siraj has
seen him watched one of his videos or
something like this
and
if if i can
maybe
frame it a little bit there is that you
were one of the first machine learning
youtubers he became really popular
quickly things went uphill
more views and so on and then
i think it's fair to say it kind of all
came crashing down in in like a very
short period of time
and
yeah then
it's it's it just sort of crumbled if i
i don't i can't really frame it any
differently there seem to be like things
one on top of another that just all came
in like a month or so the same month it
seemed it seemed crazy this this time at
the end of 2019 so yeah i'm i'm i'm
happy to to host siraj today uh thanks
so much for being here
and uh you know
talking and and
you agreed to talk a little bit about
your side of things of what happened and
what you're doing now so yeah welcome
thanks it's great to be here i love your
videos they're uh they're definitely
they've got a personality and character
to them that i definitely admire and i'd
like to see more of
thank you
and and yeah so
i thank you well since since you're
since you're the og youtuber of this you
know that i guess character is a little
bit of of what it takes i want to
go back a little bit to the beginning
though you if i if i recall correctly
you started studying economics is that
correct
correct at columbia that was my freshman
year i was an economics major
yeah
and and for some reason you switched
over to computer science
because it what what took you there
um well i was
um
i
took a semester to travel around europe
using couchsurfing i was cow surfing for
three and a half months and the first
person that i couch surfed with in
london his name was alex mccall
he showed me
um his terminal window he had a
hackintosh that he made and he really
inspired me to get into computer science
it turned out you know several years
later that alex uh wrote the book the
o'reilly book on javascript and he has
this really cool startup called clearbit
that he already sold by now um but i got
to meet him before all that happened and
once i saw alex terminal and all the
cool things he was doing i knew that
once i got back to columbia i needed to
like switch over to computer science
because that was how you really made an
impact in the world
yeah so
i
i guess you saw pretty early that the
impact was to was to be made right i
think a lot of people go into economics
and they think like they maybe think a
little bit of money if they go into
economics because it's kind of close to
it but
i i guess
computer science especially you know
nowadays is really the impactful field
or one of one of the impactful fields
little known fact i also didn't i
started out in medicine and then
switched over to computer science so so
much of the of the same journey there
and then did you did you finish computer
science or
no i dropped out um my senior year of
all times to drop out
wow yeah
and i and that was because of youtube or
no no no folks so i dropped out because
i had a robotic startup at the time
we were making a six degree of freedom
robot that would pick things up off the
floor for older people with something
called als because they can't bend over
and uh we built a prototype raised money
but it turns out like nobody would buy
it and also there were some
software problems
at the time this wasn't this was like
2012. so um
yeah i just
um moved to san francisco from there
from new york and then
that's when i really started to feel
like i was around my people
like texas
yeah you're you're american originally
but from smaller town or big city or i'm
from houston texas so i was born here my
parents are from india
um definitely have a deep connection
with india i still dream about india
um
cool and and then you were you're in san
francisco and how did you get into
youtube
so i worked at a several contract jobs
in san francisco for companies like cbs
interactive doing mobile development
i worked at meetup for a year um just as
a general software engineer i was i
started off as an intern
and then um eventually
the last job i had w2 job was at twilio
the api company
and i worked there as a developer
educator for about eight months
and then i was fired
because i
i think it was just a performance thing
i that that's what they said so i don't
know but i remember
wanting i learned a lot at twilio about
developer education and how innovative
it could be um to give you an example we
were learning about different ways of
getting developers who use the twilio
api and
you know as i was writing documentation
across nine different programming
languages like ruby and php and python
one thing that i was told by my mentor
was that we don't want to use too many
exclamation points inside of our
documentation because if you have more
than three what developers do is that
they subconsciously think of not equals
from code and that gives them a negative
impression of the text
and i was like that level of detail i
never thought about that but it really
is an art and so i started wanting to
make videos on the side and actually my
first three youtube videos i made while
i was at twilio at the conference room
at midnight when nobody was there
and i showed it to my colleagues there
and they were like
my boss was like you know that's great
that's cool we don't think developers
are going to use videos as a learning
tool they want something static like
documentation and so that's when i
thought
well
maybe there's something here
and so once i got fired i got a
severance and i had
enough to live in san francisco for
about six to eight months
and that really gave me the impetus i
remember
i had all my stuff in a box
um that they gave to me from my desk
and i
literally the day i was let go i
walked across the street to a hair salon
and then i got my hair dyed
and i was like all right i'm all in on
this youtube thing now like i have to
figure out how to make this work
did you did you
just the hair did you consciously do
that did you think i need some sort of a
thing
yeah i mean i was always inspired by um
a guy named bill nye the science guy and
how he was very unique character for
general science and i thought what is my
thing
um
i didn't know
what exactly i wanted but i remember a
roommate of mine at the time who was a
matchmaker she was like you know you'd
look really cool with like a silver
streak in your hair
i just tried it out
i mean you chose better than me the
sunglasses now i have to code with
sunglasses which is annoying
you get it you're very recognized with
the sunglasses in person
i i get i get recognized within and
without i think the hairline is gives
gives it away but uh yeah
that's how that's how our branding works
i guess
so but yeah so then you just you started
creating
videos was it always machine learning or
did you also like get into that somehow
no so we started out my first few videos
were all on bitcoin in fact my first
video was called what is bitcoin
yeah that's really
i think a bitcoin is the soul of the
hacker community um
everything comes from bitcoin and
emerges outwards from there
if i i'm not religious but mike the
closest thing to a religion would be
bitcoin
um but i started making machine learning
videos just because it seemed really
interesting and
i was really interested alphago really
was the catalyst for me like oh there's
something here let me let me start
making videos on this with no
credentials no
um phd or anything like that
yeah also
also i felt like
um this this is kind of weird to say out
loud but like i'd spent six months in
india traveling across the entire
subcontinent before i started working at
twilio and one thing that i saw was like
you know
i was living in such a box my whole life
in the united states and india's such a
beautiful country however there's a lot
of issues there it is developing country
kind of ascending country i like to say
um but
you know we can't just solve all of
these problems in our lifetime and some
of them are just they're going to take
many generations of salt perhaps if we
created some sort of super intelligence
digital organism god it could solve
everything for us and the thing that i
personally could do was use my specific
knowledge um to help make that happen in
the form of funny interesting videos
that would raise awareness around these
technologies to as many people as
possible and that would somehow increase
the amount of research happening in the
field and all of this together would
accelerate development of a super
intelligence
yeah
i mean that's
i have one socialist like borderline
communist friend and whenever i make fun
of communism has never worked he always
says like but we haven't tried with an
ai supermind planner right and then i'm
like yeah okay that's god he's got a
point right
but yeah so
when did you
so you had this plan of doing videos
when did you really see that this could
be something like was there a moment
where you saw like
wait you know
views go up and was there like a
particular moment or did it come you
know slowly or
when did you really feel like yeah i
could make this work
well i think it was three months into
making videos once a week because back
then i could only do once a week it took
about 40 to 50 hours for a single video
eventually i got up to three a week at
my peak but after three months of one
video a week i got um someone emailed me
from this company called big ml which
was a machine learning platform it was
my first
person who ever reached out to me they
wanted to pay me for a series of videos
and i was elated because ad revenue was
like you know nothing really um
i did have patreon that definitely
helped for sure but that that was my
first i think they paid me 2k usd for
six videos
um which was huge
and yeah and that was really like oh
this is something
and then of course udacity reached out
to me and that was the biggest catalyst
like for it to
help
um make their deep learning course
nanodegree yep
so
yeah udacity but but that that also
fell through if i if i recall correctly
and and this is so maybe for for people
who who don't know and you have made
you've made an extensive like apology
videos about this but it some of your
videos or or
you know to to the degree were
plagiarized not exactly the videos but
you would sort of write or show some
code and then you would say like either
like oh look at this code or watch me
build a trading bot or something like
this and and
you know just be very vague about the
origins of the code and then you would
you put attribution maybe really small
at the bottom
of the code but essentially it'd be
other people's code that you you
presented
is that about a fair framing of
of things so a lot of times you you took
other people's codes didn't fork it on
github but just kind of downloaded it
re-uploaded it and then changed the like
the readme or maybe some wrapper and
things
so
when yeah when was that do you was this
always your your mode of operating or
did you like
did you at some point start did it
increase because that's what i'm
i'm wondering like i
right you started out saying you know i
could do i could do raise awareness and
so on and you ended
by or ended you at some point you found
yourself in a mode where
you would a new video would just be like
i take someone else's code i make a
video claiming essentially
inferring that i i made it right how how
did you get from a to b
so if it was a process it didn't happen
all at once i mean if you look at my
first few videos they were like i really
did write the code for the first few
videos um they were like 10 to 20 lines
using the skills that i learned at
twilio of like making something really
basic a skeleton app that a developer
could just download it hit compile and
it runs make it as simple as possible i
would look at these very complex
repositories for the initial versions of
tensorflow and
um
you know
a neural conversational model by oriole
vignelles who's my favorite researcher
still to this day and just try to
condense it into you know 10 20 lines as
a wrapper
um but over time i just
it was like a gradual process of
you know instead of just raising
awareness it became more like
chasing clout rape making the number go
up number go up for views likes
and there was also like almost no
accountability i was a lone actor i
wasn't working with anybody um so that
definitely made it easier to do
something like that
and um
eventually like once i moved from san
francisco to los angeles um
and that was the last
year and a half that i worked on youtube
um so from 2018 to 2019
that's when um i think that was a bad
move like i not really an la person but
that's when i really started to um
really chase the clout
and pursue fame for the sake of it
because i'd already gotten these
opportunities
and it seemed like
i just needed to get to a million
subscribers no matter what
yeah
a million is was that your personal goal
or i mean for for me a million was
always the point a little bit where you
could live off of ad revenue was was it
like this or was it just a number you
liked or no it was just a number it was
just like a fun little goal in my head
yeah
it so and did you did you
did you at any point feel like uh maybe
i shouldn't do this maybe at the
beginning and did it become easier for
you or how did you
think about yourself
or did you
just think you know everyone else is
doing it or
yeah i mean i
i guess i you know everybody is a
protagonist of their own story right i
felt like i was doing
you know just having the little name in
the very bottom of the github not
forking the code but just putting it
down there that made me
you know feel guilt-free
um yeah at the time but obviously that
wasn't how i should have done it
i mean
obviously what you did was was very
public and therefore the backlash i felt
was also very public i mean a lot of a
lot of people
got angry
and and you know once once it all let's
say came crashing down a lot of people
came forward and said oh yeah me too
i was also my code was plagiarized and
so on
i i i feel like i have seen
exactly stuff like this in research it
like
tons of times people
essentially copying papers
mildly
attributing like once but essentially
the entire page would be would be like
taken from
usually it's their or earlier papers so
what authors will do is they will have
like one new equation
and then they'll write an eight page
paper where seven and a half pages are
essentially their old paper right and uh
so so i mean
but that is never it's never as public
right it's never as as as as big i guess
the more public one is
the
the worse it gets when something like
this really
really happens
uh did you
so i know i've read
your udacity course that you you said
that became an issue there right people
try to tell you you can't
plagiarize stuff is that is that correct
or
so i i've seen it like a tweet from
someone at udacity saying you know the
the course fell through essentially
because they try to tell you
that that's not how they do things
or
what is or maybe you can tell a little
bit
what the the udacity course you said
that was a big thing for you why did it
fall through yeah so
you know
the what happened with udacity was we
had a 16 week course that i essentially
designed and then udacity helped me
build a team around that to help me
one issue that one of the people at
udacity had that i was working with he
was also in the initial trailer video
matt leonard was that i was not writing
the code from scratch
i was using existing examples
and he didn't like that
um we also didn't have that good a
working relationship during the course
but i think in terms of falling through
um that happened like
you know everybody made money from that
course including udacity
and there were several cohorts of
students that didn't just run once i
think it ran like three or four times
you actually udacity actually approached
approached me two years after that
course was over to do another version of
it and i did help get that too
um in terms of following through yeah
when all of this happened then you know
people came out and said this stuff
yeah i don't know what happened with the
courts honestly i haven't okay i think
maybe uh maybe i got i got this one this
one wrong
um
yes and
so
i've seen like i've looked at your your
social blade and and so on you're you're
at about 700 k subscribers and i've seen
also an interview
with lex friedman and you where
essentially you you also told him like
you know what matters to me is views
i'm i'm attuned to
to views to more subscribers and and so
on uh is it fair to say a little bit
that
you might have lost sight of
you know the bigger picture or or other
things just in in pursuit of this goal
it is it is i was definitely
disillusioned with
um agi and the initial goals that i had
at the start
i definitely also had a
you know an issue with uh i had like a
drug problem near the end
i was doing
too much of a
certain drug that makes you really um
up and have a lot of energy
and there was a point where i pretty
much almost overdosed on it
and that's when i knew like i even like
you know called the cops on myself to
because i thought i was going to die
i don't i've never really said this out
loud before but
that was near the end this is basically
like a month or two before
um you know that scandal happened
and i was just you know
i just felt like
i was unfallible like i was untouchable
like i could do no wrong
and
yeah i'd never had that level of fame
before as well like that was pretty
that was it was quite a drug of its own
as well on top of that
but yeah it was a gradual process i
think of going from uplifting developers
and like that being the primary concern
to also then
chasing clout chasing fame
wanting more opportunity more views um
more recognition
and
just making uh stupid decisions
yeah i can i mean i'm
you know as as a as a another youtuber i
i
get the draw of this like i unders i can
i i get this feeling of being sucked
into these into these metrics and it's
not only the metrics right the metrics
are correlated with money
correlated with fame and so on uh i i
like
yeah i i see the
and so many youtubers fall into this
right and uh your your mistake was also
a little bit that
you
your your setting
was
in an maybe like an academic or a
professional setting where people
actually
care about you know not stealing stuff
and things like this so maybe
you know you
unluckily for you chose the wrong field
to do something like this and because in
many other fields i think this would
have just you know been been completely
fine so
in addition to let's say making videos
and you were making insane number of
videos like two a week or three a week
as you said and that certainly also you
had a schedule
that certainly must have also pressured
you
but then you also there is this there's
the issue with your paper right and that
that to me that to me
was really something where i thought
this is someone who who is
almost like blinded by
either the speed or or the fame or or as
you said you felt infallible or
something like this so for people who
don't know
you had
written a number of research papers but
this particular one
you even made a video about it i think
like i wrote a paper in a week or
something like and uh it was about it
was about the neural the neural qubit
and
one of your viewers then
uh
went public and
claimed and and could show that this was
copied from largely from two other
papers copied together the diagrams
copied and the text copied and you you
changed
some of the wording
which was the most puzzling thing to me
so instead of a
quantum
gate which is equivalent to a logic gate
you changed it to a quantum door which
makes no i like this is a meme until
today right and and instead of complex
uh numbers or complex hilbert spaces i
think it was uh complicated hilbert
spaces which also is is kind of
if you so maybe if you just if you look
back now
what is what is your reaction now to to
past you in with respect to that that
paper
yeah
um yeah that was hilarious
that's eternally a meme now um
what i
yeah i mean i used ai to
generate some words and like make things
different
i
what so this was automated the
replacement yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah i think there's a tool called like
um i think it's called like
it's it's a web tool i forgot it's like
ai writer or something like that you
like paste in a paragraph and then it
like rewrites it
um
yeah like what a super decision that was
i but there there i mean at this point
it's really it's not it's not it's not
this
it's not quite it's a step up from
copying code and attributing someone at
the bottom right because there you can
still say
you know i attributed them i'm you know
i can sleep at night this is really
i go i take paper i put it deliberately
into a tool that rewords it and then i
say here's my here's my paper right this
is
what what made you or
how did you
how did you find
yourself making that that step that
you know like they're really from
i can
justify this to myself to
i guess i don't know what maybe you
explain better than me
yeah i you know
it's just like ego it's like i'm
untouchable and i can just do anything
and i
um i guess i didn't really understand
what it's like
before i plagiarized that paper i talked
to an actual quantum researcher
um who works at in santa barbara for
google and um
you know he's like we should write this
you know i was like we should write this
paper together he's like yeah let's do
it it's going to take a year and i
remember thinking like that's way too
long for me like i'm not doing that in a
year i'm going to do this in three days
and just thinking like
you know i guess i didn't respect the
scientific process enough to
yeah it was just um to me i just thought
of it as like a another link in the
video description
just adding it i should have just linked
to the seven papers i just
instead i put my name on it and just
made it into one and
like oh people are going to like me more
because of this
i'll have more credibility because of
this instead of the opposite
and
i don't know it was just in general it's
just
you know really um
drugged out honestly like that i don't
know
why
i made a lot of decisions that i did um
i'm so over now about the way yeah yeah
at no point it did it did it ever
because that's that's the baffling thing
to me a little bit and that that that
shows me or at least seems a little bit
like someone who has really lost touch a
bit is is that when some when a it's
like a an experienced researcher tells
me it's gonna take a year to write a
paper
and
sure if i think i'm fast i can i think i
can do it in three months right but
three days is a
like is a different thing so so
clearly
your idea was already you know i'm gonna
take a shortcut it's not like i'm gonna
write the same paper in three days it's
just
um how can i make a video out of this in
the shortest possible time
yeah i was like what's my next video i
wrote a research paper and just thinking
about that
that's really the angle like i want to
make a video that shows or tells people
that i wrote a research paper
yeah yeah
so a lot of i've seen a lot of
commentary saying things like you know
it's it's a shame you have a you have a
good platform you're charismatic and you
could have
they say
something along the lines of
you you might have just as well
credited all these people
and just had the same effect like
implying you know there would be another
way of doing this you could just say you
know here is a bunch of code by some
cool people i'm going to show you how it
works
uh and and
their implication is
you would be just as famous you would be
just as liked and so on did you
first of all do you think that's true
and second of all
did you think that's true like or
was it really your conviction no
if i did that i would be
way less popular
i do think that that's true now
i did not think that was true that
i thought that i would have to be the
guy with who is behind all of this in
order for my
brand and channel to grow
because
yeah because
it's just hard like in the youtube game
to like
differentiate yourself and i felt like
this was a way i could do that
yeah i mean
it's
it's it is true right um i'm not sure
that these people are correct like it's
for sure good advice to credit the
people whose work you present but i
myself i'm not sure if they are correct
when they say you would have been just
as popular and
and and just as as
you know well respected by the people
who think you really did do these things
right i'm not sure as you say how how
youtube works is
it's a
it's a tough game
and
you at some some point
this this all came and together also
with your with your course which we can
talk about in a second but
specifically with respect to the the
code and and to the paper you made an
apology video which was
fairly lengthy it was not your usual
style it was just kind of you standing
there
you you essentially said
straightforwardly you know here's what i
did i credit i
didn't credit these people enough just
took their code
and and so on
and
um
then
people noticed that only like a few days
later in your next videos
essentially you did the same thing like
there there were slides where
where you you took from somewhere and so
on is it
i don't know is it fair to say and so
you made these videos you made the
apology videos then you immediately
started uploading videos and before you
really quit and you quit for a long time
after that
what was what were sort of the last
videos like for you
or
you know like
after let's say the apology video and so
but before you quit what was that like
you're asking about the time between
when i quit to the apology video what
that was like
no from the apology video
to the point where you
it didn't upload for for months after
that or uploaded very infrequently
was how did you feel at the point like
of the apology video and and a little
after that
yeah well i mean it felt pretty bad
generally i'm a pretty happy guy as you
can surma but um i can say that's the
only time in my life where i've ever
felt somewhat suicidal like uh just for
a little bit
and uh
yeah i didn't know how to deal with that
level of sadness so i tried about a
bunch of different things like i
um
moved from la i
uh got a dog
i
just i don't know did some soul
searching some meditation just tried out
a bunch of
i tried virtual reality like escapism as
well
um
it was a pretty tough time as you can
imagine but in terms of like
doing the same thing again
i guess i did but i didn't think that i
was like maybe there's something wrong
with me like i just
i don't know i don't know like i i need
i need some kind of mentor to be like
here is how you credit people in a
youtube video about machine learning and
here is what people are going to
find acceptable
yeah did you did you think
at some point
maybe i can turn this around you know
maybe i can
because because you were at the
beginning when when people brought these
things up you were i i saw just a bunch
of twitter posts and so on sort of
discrediting them denying them like no i
never
did anything like this was there a point
where you thought you know
people are getting iffy maybe i can turn
it around
yeah yeah there was um i mean i tried
everything i was like maybe i don't need
to apologize maybe i do that would make
it better or worse
maybe i should just deny didn't i deny
like politicians do
maybe i should
you know make fun of you know make like
uh
um reply videos to other youtubers who
made videos about me
there's a lot of things that i thought i
could do
um
eventually i decided and i don't even
know if
that was the best thing for my brand i
know it was the right thing to do to
make an apology video morally
but i don't know if that actually helped
me or hurt me i still don't know to this
day
um
yeah
was it so i i think if i hear this a
little bit out of you that there was a
time
where you were still mainly thinking
brand mainly thinking you know which
actions are gonna let me still reach
like the million subscribers or continue
on and then was there a particular point
where you thought
no actually you know let's let's do an
apology let's let's tone it down
um was there was there a time when you
thought
when you consciously let go maybe of the
million subscriber goal there was there
was i
think it just came from
introspection and
seeing how like the
um
the amount of um
i don't even know what you want to call
it uh
feedback negative feedback or
um criticism he just
wouldn't go away he was just there
and
it didn't really die down i thought
i mean there's really nothing else i can
do here i need to just accept defeat
wave the white flag
um part of my brand is just like you
know super confidence and
always being um
okay with being
um like haters or whatever
not even yes but you know what i mean
and like
there was a point where i was like ah
you know i'll just
apologize and then i also felt you know
near the end i did feel i started to
feel like guilty because
you know some people said that it wasn't
just that i plagiarized but that
i was actually
doing the opposite of like accelerating
um researching the space like this sets
a bad example for people and this
actually gets in the way of research and
it's going to slow it down and that's
what i was like okay
that's if that's true that's really bad
and honestly i like i was reading too
many comments as well
um
but yeah i mean
i still don't know to this day like
whether or not
um the apology video helped or hurt my
brand in fact
if i had to ben i would say probably
hurt my brand
but
you know at least i felt better
afterwards and
i guess that's what mattered in the end
yeah i mean
i think few people really
understand what what it's like to get
youtube comments on a on on a bit of a
scale and and and people there will
there will always be people criticizing
and hating especially i guess you with
very little credentials in the field
i guess you have always had people
saying you know this is a maybe this is
a clown
uh has no credentials what not and
it didn't help that you
copied code because then you not
authoring the code also meant you knew
less about the code which might also be
sometimes shine through a bit in your
videos but i think you with time you you
sort of learn to tune out
the haters because you're gonna get them
anyway but then
sometimes they're right right and and i
think it's i think you know
i don't think and uh
i don't think many people in the like
public sphere
get like have a good good understanding
of when should i listen to the to the
bad comments and when not because
usually it's no right so right yeah
um
so then then this this was this was very
shortly people really complaining about
plagiarized code and uh this this paper
which was one of the sort of big
points raised and then in a very sure
like within a month or so there was also
the issue of a course you offered right
so you
you
maybe can you tell a bit how this course
even came to be you you made videos at
an insane rate
how did you how did you think you could
also offer a course and and why
yeah i think it comes down to two things
one i felt like i could do more than
what i actually was capable of doing
because i
my ego was so inflated at the time
so i that's one the other is just
looking at the metrics generally the
videos
that were about making money were the
ones that did the best
and so i started to follow that trend
and tailor my content in that direction
as opposed to what i would have done
years ago which is like how do we solve
them you know millennium problems like
poverty reduction and water cleanliness
and
um environmental sustainability things
that you know actually matter the course
was around that like well if people want
to make money
let me make a course around making money
with machine learning
that was what is called right it was
called make money with machine learning
literally that is a hell of a clickbait
yeah like the most clickbaity
exactly what's going to get the views
title
and it was supposed to be
a
paid course it was i think about 200
per student and
the issue the first issue was that you
claimed it was like a limited
entry course with personal supervision
now both of these things didn't really
turn out to be
accurate as as you promised so there was
an issue of you said i only let in 500
people
but then
you let in twice 500 people so you you
had two different slack work workspaces
with twice
the five some i think one even had 700
but
there's a few extra ones
i guess and then also there was
apparently not really
like you can't you can't personally
supervise a thousand two hundred like
it's impossible did you
plan on these things already or did they
just sort of
how did they happen
i didn't plan on them i did think that i
would have 500 um but when i put the
course out
there were so many sign ups so fast and
i got greedy i was like i'm just like
i'm just gonna let this keep on going
let's see how many people can sign up
for this
and i thought yeah i can just have two
different uh
cohorts and
um you know i had people volunteer to
help at the time
you helped me like as i guess you called
them teaching assistants
and
yeah but they they how many
roughly how many tas did you have
do you remember um there was at least
one there might have been written that
there's at least one
yeah
but they they sort of did they quit
after a while or did they stick with you
well no they actually they were amazing
they stuck the whole time yeah
okay
but they were they were volunteers yeah
yeah okay so
it was 200 bucks and like one two three
maybe volunteer tas for a thousand two
hundred
students
and
you
did you
plan on on ramp did you realize at some
point i can't provide personal feedback
to all of these students or or did you
just think
you know whatever i'll i'll just i can
do this or
i did i did realize i was in over my
head i i think it was like week two or
week three
that it really started to dawn on me
um and then i think
i think it was week four
that some of the students started you're
going to social media
um
and then everything came crashing down
in the middle of the course
and then
i had to give out a bunch of refunds
but still had to finish the course to
the end it was a 10-week course
so we still have to keep going for five
weeks after that
um
but yeah i mean there were still you
know hundreds of students who stayed in
the course i don't know know that like
the register made an article on this but
they didn't say like
it's not like everybody just dropped out
all of a sudden yeah still people in the
course i i still had some responsibility
yeah so i i maybe briefly summarize
these these articles and
you know they're they're written from a
certain angle right and uh that's that's
exactly why i also wanted to get your
just your side of of this story so these
articles they claim for example that you
know people started noticing there was
no personal supervision they complained
um you you you never essentially showed
up in the slack workspaces well
you know
or or infrequently they all got the same
feedback on their exercise so that was
the sort of like a copy paste of like
good job
um
it was it was like that then people
started demanding
refunds
but were some claim they were even
banned like
for
demanding refunds
then
it was also claimed that
you
eventually said there was a refund
period
which was for 14 days
but
the article claimed you quietly
introduced the refund period 30 days
after the course started so it was
essentially impossible
for anyone to have
known because there was no refund policy
at the beginning you introduced a 14-day
refund period 30 days after the co the
course started you then and then you
know once once people discovered that
there were two different cohorts and
so on or how
what of these articles
is
is true and what is overdone
um
so there are also several several tweets
of students that said yeah people
claiming refunds were
were banned um
or or
that the fact that you introduced this
refund period how did this go down from
your perspective
so paul that is true um what i don't i
think was overblown is the banning part
i never personally banned anybody
um but i can't speak to whether or not
one of the tas may or may not have done
that
i love you
but yeah everything else like definitely
um on point like it's all part of
the
the story yeah can't refute any of that
yeah
and
did you did you get
did you get scared at any point or did
you were you still in this you because
all of a sudden
people and their money are involved
right it's not i mean 200 200 bucks is
not that much for maybe an american but
it is a lot for maybe someone in india
or or something you know at some place
like this
did you get at some point
you know scared because like wow there's
actual money here that i may have to pay
back or
yeah i mean i got scared for a lot of
reasons i was scared that
um yeah i would like have to go through
some kind of lawsuits people were saying
like oh i'm gonna there's gonna be a
lawsuit you're lucky you're not in jail
and stuff and
um
yeah about the refund stuff like that 30
day versus sneaking it in and i'm sure
i'm sure i did that i honestly don't
remember it now like i'm sure like
that's probably what happened
but
i mean when i look at it now i'm like i
mean
when you charge money you need to be
very upfront with people and like that's
how you make a sustainable product i
wasn't thinking very sustainably and
long-term
it was a very short-term thing
um
but i was scared yeah i was here
did you
but but your thought was still i can
educate these people even if i can't
give them personal supervision or or was
it was it all like you know like i'm
gonna get their 200 bucks i'm gonna tell
them something so they can't complain or
did you still think
you know i can't like the course has
value for the people who are in it no i
i did think the course had value i mean
it's it's weird because it's like i'm
conflating
my
bias against academia and the
traditional learning path with this
course that is yeah it's got a super
clickbait title
but
you know i guess i didn't fully
appreciate what
online learning and i'm still learning
what online learning really can be in
the future i thought well you know you
don't need to be in a physical classroom
to learn like i think we can all agree
to that now like you can watch videos
online
but also
you know what is um
personal supervision and does there need
to be x y and z for someone to be able
to say i learned a lot of learning comes
from self motivation and
um
you know
education is not a scarce resource it's
it's abundant it's the
desire to learn that is scarce and
perhaps that alone i felt justified like
if i could get them to want to learn
these things that would be enough um at
the time i felt that way now i know like
what would i change differently besides
the obvious part like the 30 day refund
from the start
is to
just hire help like if i were to give
advice to anybody doing anything like
this like any youtuber who wants to make
a course like hire help step one hire
help then figure everything else out
don't plan it out yourself
it's too big it's too big at scale for
one person to do
what what happened did you end up giving
refunds to to people or i did did did
you still have enough money to give
refunds
um i
yeah i did what what happened to the
money like i i can imagine you get
200 bucks a thousand people that's like
200k
um
how where where did that go did you end
up
plus or minus or did you spend on
refunds did any lawsuit result or
there were no lawsuits everybody who
wanted a refund got a refund there were
still a bunch of students who completed
the course to the end like
and i'm very thankful like despite all
the drama
they were loyal to the to the thing and
so was it it wasn't negative it was
positive it wasn't nearly like probably
like 10 percent what i mean at the start
and
and then
you know i i think
this as i said this was within like a
month of
of every everything down you you were
making lots videos the paper the course
all at the same time
and then everything everything comes
crashing and
i think it's one it's one thing
when you feel bad because life is is
crap right because
something happened to you
that's bad and you know but it's an
entirely different thing
when you're you you know
you're responsible for it right like
that is that is worse that is like my
life is bad and i'm to blame and it you
know like it's it's my
my doing right
like
was this
i guess this was your experience right
you know whether you thought it was good
or bad it was like my life is crap and
i'm responsible how did you
what did you do at that point you you
said bit of soul searching and so on how
did you
decide to to go forward
um so i moved back to san francisco um i
was there for a few months
i
basically
invested in my friends and family talked
to them that helped
um got really into virtual reality that
helped as well like disassociating from
this reality bring it to a virtual world
um where i was anonymous
and uh logged off of all social media as
well so that helped as well
and kind of just gave up with the whole
like you know million subscriber
path that i was on
and
what else yeah just um oh yeah focus on
my health as well like i was like
i'm just gonna like
try to focus on being healthy because i
can control that i can't control what
people think about i can control my
health
so that helps you you made a you made a
quite astounding
uh
body fitness transformation as well you
were at the end you were like in 2019
when it all crashed you were kind of a
like a chubster yeah like
right
and i i saw like a before after picture
was this a conscious effort by you or
it was it was yeah because like
part of like what you know having a
desire to live is to like be able to
look in the mirror and you know say like
for me at least like hey this is an
attractive guy
so that you know it's kind of vain but
it definitely helped for sure like that
yeah
and
so you you eventually you got
let's say back up on your on your feet
after all of this what was your or what
is your current
plan or what are you doing right now
you've you've posted a few videos again
here and there but
um
i'm not so maybe
you know what's what are you doing
essentially so um yeah making videos
along this series called alpha care
about health care and ai which has kind
of always been like my
the industry i'm most excited about for
ai like applicability like oh we can
make people healthier so i'm doing that
i'm almost done with the book i've been
writing for the past three months
um
which it's gonna be a free e-book i'm
not gonna charge for it
um
so that's been interesting that's also
on like uh deep learning for healthcare
apps for begetters
a bunch of examples in there
and once i release that all of this will
be done in like three weeks probably
from now
um like the siri the video series in the
book then i have to figure out what the
next thing i'm going to do is
um what i'm most excited about currently
is
paying people to be healthy
um there's this app called sweat coin
it's out of the united kingdom it pays
people in cryptocurrency to walk i find
that really really interesting because
you know two of the most meaningful
things to me are
um keeping people healthy and reducing
poverty and this kind of does both at
the same time so i'm wondering if
there's a way to create what's called a
dao a distributed autonomous
organization around
um health care and health data and
keeping people healthy paying them
somehow with cryptocurrency to stay
healthy
i just use a service called inside
tracker which cost me like 500 bucks
way too expensive a service for most
people to use um but i got a blood test
done two weeks ago using the service
they took 43 biomarkers of mine and that
now i have a bunch of health data like
my cholesterol level is apparently way
too high because i way too much red meat
um so i've got to cut down on that but
something like this if we could turn
into
um
like a free service
that keeps people healthy and actually
not just free but pay them money and
then somehow turn it into a business
where also the service makes money
that'd be really cool so i'm kind of
like thinking like i'm going to start
some kind of company around that or a
dow i should say i'm not exactly sure
what it looks like though
i mean there this is happening in part
already with i don't know we have like
high taxes on on cigarettes right so
essentially the the smokers they finance
a little bit
the non-smokers via taxes
some health insurances they already give
discounts if you do like regularly go to
it to a gym or something so
i'm like something like this is
definitely in the in the realm of of
possibilities now with respect to
cryptocurrency is this a meme or was
there actually a siraj coin at some
point
i haven't found anything like what
what was that
yeah that was a real thing i launched a
cryptocurrency i think two years ago or
something three i don't know uh called
siraj floyd
and uh people really didn't like it
so i took down the video i'm like
there's still
you could find it if you really search
siraj coin
okay
but it was just it was more like for a
video or did you think you know maybe i
could make some money with launching my
own cryptocurrency yeah both i mean this
was at the height of the
um ico
crate yeah and everybody was doing it
and i felt like wow i'm gonna do it too
here we go that's right
and the idea was that you can with siraj
coin you can uh get a meeting like buy a
meeting with me or like make a music
video with me just you know i am the
scarce resource like in these cryptos
there is a scarce resource created token
the token is how you access the scarce
resource
yeah and uh
yeah i mean i'm glad i did it still like
nobody got hurt from that it was just
like a fun experiment and i learned a
lot from it as well like i still think
it's an interesting idea like i do think
that we're gonna see more individuals
create tokens around themselves
and
um
yeah
i mean yeah a couple of nfts work this
way right that there's some kind of like
a meeting with a famous person tagged
onto it or something like this
yeah so
with with respect to your
your book and your new set of videos
and you know i guess the question
everyone asks is
is there still
how how do you handle citations
plagiarism things like this are you are
you toning it down or are you like extra
super duper careful or what is your
sort of how do you approach this topic i
guess you're in a bit of a special
situation not not only
are you held to the same standards but
now
you know people read your name they're
probably the first thing they do is put
something into a plagiarism checker
yeah i'm super careful i put it in the
video description not just like the
github i say it verbally
um
yeah i just try to be more careful
um yeah
and the what's the book about can you is
there is it something you can disclose
already or
yeah it's on bioinformatics for
beginners i'm also a beginner to bio
informatics i'm really interested in
multicomics like all the homics genomics
hepa genomics transcriptomics
and just thinking about how we can
integrate all of these different types
of data to make both diagnostic and
prognostic
predictions for
people and
i think that's the future i'm really
interested in reversing the aging
process
um david sinclair pat harbert has a
great book on this called why we age and
why we don't have to he has a podcast
that he's going to release next year on
this topic and i just think that there's
a great space for data science and data
analyst enthusiasts to make a
contribution in this field because i do
think the future of health care isn't
going to be targeting individual
diseases like alzheimer's or heart
disease but rather that this
the disease that is upstream of
everything else aging itself
that's a i mean it's a tough task um
but yeah it's a it's a i guess it's a
cool
cool outlook i it seems like a little
bit of a rebirth it you know you told
how you were at the beginning of your
video career thinking if i could just
you know make video about these cool
topics and so on
and uh
it it almost feels or at least to me it
sounds like
it's got a little bit of that same
spirit again
i'd like to think so i mean i i don't
have the same i don't know i don't have
the same level of
or maybe i just feel this way i don't
have the same like energy
that i did back then
um
where it's just like a i have to do this
or else like
the world is gonna end like that level
of conviction
i just feel like
hey i mean i'm really interested in
biology in general i don't think i'm
gonna get i honestly don't think
this is gonna give me the level of
fame or opportunity that talking about
deep learning from 316 to 2020 did it's
just something i'm interested in
uh and i'm okay like not reaching a
million up i mean probably never going
to reach a million subscribers i just
want to be interested in this and even
if and you know if this like company
doesn't work out i'm happy to like take
a job somewhere and just like learn
about bioinformatics full-time as a
bioinformatician
halos or something um
yeah
well in yeah i mean in many ways i i've
told you that this this privately but in
in many ways you were
you're sort of with with all of this
happening you were still sort of a the
pioneer
of
what many of of us other ml youtubers
essentially that the path we go
is
you you made it it kind of like i
remember when i started making videos
there was like nothing
and when you started there must have
been like really really nothing right
and um
you know that for for for all the things
i think it took it took balls to to go
that way and and you you certainly
hustled even if it led in into like a
wrong direction
um
do you have
i don't know do you have do you have
because i know there are quite a number
of people who look at maybe you also me
other youtubers
a lot of people are starting their
podcasts nowadays a lot of people also
start channels like mine or or similar
to mine any advice you have
for people starting out in in the
in the sphere of
online education or
what might what we might call being an
influencer anything like this um yeah i
would say that
you this is not something you do as a
side job like a lot of people you know
kind of have to because they need a
source of income from their day job
but
um
i would say like the only way to be
successful in this is to
pick hits to be your one fate and do
that
all day and it's got to feel like
play to you but it's got to look like
work to other people like to me
this whole time i've just been playing
like really enjoying myself like it's
not work and that's honestly why i think
i grew as much as i did i genuinely
enjoy the topics i genuinely enjoy the
video production process editing
lighting thinking about metrics all of
that stuff just felt like play to me and
that's how you're going to be successful
it's not going to be if you feel like
it's hard work
um you should pivot or think of some
other content to talk about or maybe a
different medium like you know i had a
podcast as well um i did i think five
interviews and then i stopped because it
didn't feel like play to me like i don't
actually
yeah for some reason i just don't enjoy
being a podcast host like i enjoy
monologues
and that kind of thing so i stopped
um whereas someone like you or you know
joe rogan or other podcasters they
actually enjoy it so they're gonna
they're actually gonna be successful so
that's that's my best advice is like
make sure that it feels like play to you
and then i you will be you'll probably
be successful
and when someone finds themselves a bit
successful and finds themselves to be
sucked and drawn by
the metrics by the cloud by
because i already i already said it but
i'm gonna say it again like this is a
this is a thing i feel it i like other
youtubers feel it for sure this this
suck it's like a it's like a thing
drawing you right and
you know leading
to the kinds of decisions you made and
and uh
what is do you have any
i don't know you know other than don't
do it do you have any
you know best the mindset that that
creates in a person do you have any any
maybe recognition of what could help
someone to
to get out of it or or to resist or you
know what do you tell yourself
when
there's like a really easy opportunity
to get a lot of views or or clicks
i would say the best thing you can do is
google sir roger ball and happen to this
guy
and uh yeah just be afraid you don't
want that to happen to you for sure
luckily it happened to me first so
you've got an example in front of you
now
of what can go wrong when you follow
views and likes too much
you chase clout too much in the
education space
um
the internet gives everybody a voice you
will be held accountable
um there is no
um we are moving into a world that is
much more transparent every day less and
less privacy
um
yeah the internet gives everybody a
voice and power so
um
yeah that's that's what i can say
use it use it wisely i guess use it
wisely
well
siraj raval this was this was
a pleasure really truly i
i
thank you very much for for being here
with me today
um thanks for coming on thanks for being
so open and and forward and and and
honest i think it's very valuable the
world also hears from you
and
you know in it not just from articles
and and and you know reviews and things
like this
absolutely thank you yannick
awesome